- This episode of LegalEagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
Michael Cohen testified
in front of Congress
for over seven hours.
I have some thoughts.
(epic music)
Hey LegalEagles, it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Today we are covering the
testimony of Michael Cohen,
President Trump's former personal lawyer
and longtime legal and extralegal fixer.
Because Cohen testified for so long,
I can't cover absolutely everything
that happened in the hearing.
This is going to be a compilation
of the different things
that I think are particularly interesting.
So I wanna point out some
of the legal principles
that I think are incredibly
important during this hearing,
but I also wanna point out
some of the rhetorical devices
that Cohen himself and Congress people
on either side of the aisle are using
to make their points and ask effective,
and sometimes not effective
questions of Cohen.
Now it's important to recognize
that there are several
purposes to this hearing,
and it also depends on
what particular side
you're playing for.
The first is to confirm or dispute
the actual testimony of Michael Cohen.
So much of what he said in the hearing
was already out in the news,
but there's a big difference
between speculation
about what he may testify
to and actual evidence
in the form of his testimony
on the record, under oath.
The second is to get
additional information
that you had no idea existed before,
the inside story that only
Michael Cohen is privy to.
And so for the Democrat's perspective,
I'm sure that they want
to get both evidence
of illegal conduct,
but also things that are just
embarrassing and potentially
don't necessarily rise to
the level of illegality,
but are just bad for the Republicans
and the President himself.
On the other hand, the
Republicans want new information
to discredit Michael Cohen
and to show the world
why no one should believe him.
And the third purpose is
to get your message out,
regardless of the
testimony that Cohen gave,
you knew that a lot of the politicians
were going to grandstand,
because the world was watching
and it was a forum to
get their message out.
Whether you wanted to
discredit the investigation,
or whether you wanted to bolster it.
Now, as always, I want the
comments to have a vigorous
but civil discussion.
Remember that Stella is
watching all of your comments,
and she wields the ban hammer of truth,
so make sure all of your
comments are Stella appropriate.
And smash that like button.
All right, so let's dig into the testimony
of Michael Cohen in front of Congress.
- Some will certainly ask
if Mr. Cohen was lying then,
why should we believe him now?
- [Man] Good question.
- This is a legitimate question.
I had made abundantly clear to Mr. Cohen
that if he comes here today,
and he does not tell him the
truth, tell us the truth,
I will be the first one to refer
those untruthful statements to DOJ.
- So one of the things
that Congressman Cummings
is doing here is what
we call front-running,
which is when you know you have a bad fact
or there is bad evidence out there.
The worst thing you could
possibly do is hide it
and pretend it doesn't exist.
So he's getting out in
front of that bad fact
and laying the groundwork
for why we should believe Cohen now,
and trying to take the sting
out of the Republican attack.
This is a classic and very
important trial tactic
that he's using here.
- Mr. Trump did not directly
tell me to lie to Congress.
That's not how he operates.
In conversations we had
during the campaign,
at the same time, I was
actively negotiating
in Russia for him.
He would look me in the eye and tell me
there's no Russian business,
and then go on to lie
to the American people.
- It's really interesting to me
that Cohen says specifically
that Trump did not
explicitly direct him to lie to Congress.
You would think that if
he really was engaging
in scorched-earth tactics,
he might as well say that
Trump directed him to do it.
That probably would get him a better deal
with the investigators and prosecutors,
but credibility is incredibly important.
And for him to go out but not
all the way he possibly could,
that helps bolster his credibility
and helps silence critics
that he's just simply
arguing over sour grapes
about not getting a
job at the White House.
- Because Mr. Trump had made clear to me
through his personal statements to me,
that we both knew to be false.
And through his lies to the country,
that he wanted me to lie.
And he made it clear to me,
because his personal attorneys
reviewed my statement
before I gave it to Congress.
- This is huge.
I mean, this alone is quite a bombshell,
that President Trump's personal attorneys
reviewed Cohen's statement,
which is verifiably false to Congress,
and is one of the reasons
that Cohen is going to jail.
Number one, I would suggest
that those attorneys
lawyer up, if they haven't done so already
because it's entirely possible
that if they knew that
the changes that they made
to Michael Cohen's testimony were false,
they can be liable and
guilty of suborning perjury.
And the prosecutors are able to show
that the President was aware
of and directed his attorneys
to make those changes,
that can make the President
guilty of suborning perjury.
There are some pretty heavy
intent requirements there.
It was recently reported
that Michael Cohen
has given Congress copies of the changes
that President Trump's
attorneys made to his statement
that gave rise to him pleading
guilty to lying to Congress.
Those statements could
be incredibly damning.
I would not expect any of those statements
to be protected by
attorney-client privilege
because I think the
joint defense agreement
has been breached.
And I don't think the attorney-client
or work-product protection would apply
because of the crime-fraud exception.
So if I was the President's attorney,
I would be very worried
about what those documents
show to Congress.
- I wound up touting the Trump
narrative for over a decade.
That was my job, always stay on message,
always defend.
It monopolized my life.
At first, I worked mostly
on Real Estate developments
and other business transactions.
Shortly thereafter, Mr. Trump brought me
into his personal life
and private dealings.
- A lot of people have asked me how it is
that Michael Cohen can testify
to communications he had
with Mr. Trump before he became President,
since Michael Cohen is an attorney
and communications with attorneys
are supposed to be protected?
Well, it's a great question,
but it's one that's very easily answered.
Attorney-client protections only protect
communications that are made between
attorneys and their clients
when attorneys are acting as an attorney.
If you have an attorney friend
who is working as an employee
or a business person,
just because they're an attorney,
that doesn't necessarily mean
that attorney-client
privilege will attach.
And Michael Cohen, for most of his career,
it appears that he was
rarely acting as an attorney
and was really just acting
mostly as an extralegal thug,
and potentially as a business
person, a business associate.
So all of those communications
that Mr. Cohen had with Mr. Trump,
when Mr. Cohen was not acting
in his capacity as an actual lawyer,
are not protected by
attorney-client privilege.
- When he was President
of the United States,
pursuant to the coverup
which was the basis of my guilty plea
to reimburse me the word
used by Mr. Trump's TV lawyer
for the illegal hush money
I paid on his behalf.
This $35,000 check was one
of a 11 check installments
that was paid throughout the
year while he was President.
Other checks to reimburse me
for the hush money payments
were signed by Donald Trump
Jr. and Allen Weisselberg.
- So this is fairly damning
evidence from Michael Cohen
that the President of the United States,
his son, Donald Trump Jr. and the CFO
of the Trump Organization all engaged
in a criminal conspiracy
to engage in election
and financial fraud by
hiding these payments
in order to prevent that
information from becoming public,
and potentially affecting
the outcome of the election.
We have, of course, known about this
for quite some time now,
but Michael Cohen is going to jail
for his part in this criminal conspiracy.
And it's hard to imagine
how that doesn't apply
to Donald Trump Jr., the President,
or Allen Weisselberg as well.
Cohen states that this conspiracy existed
before the election, was
designed to affect the election,
and it continued into the
Presidency when Donald Trump
signed a personal check
while he was President.
There's just no way to sugarcoat this.
It's hard to see how more people
aren't going to go to jail
over this particular act, if not others,
since Michael Cohen is
already going to jail for it.
- I have provided the
committee with copies of Tweets
that Mr. Trump posted
attacking me and my family.
And only someone burying
his head in the sand
would not recognize
them for what they are.
So encouragement to someone to
do harm to me and my family.
- Yeah, so the Presidential Tweets
that surrounded this testimony,
including some Tweets from Congressmen
like Congressman Matt Gaetz,
were so borderline witness intimidation
that you have to wonder
what they were thinking
when they made those statements.
Here, Cohen isn't establishing
that they constitute witness tampering,
that requires showing that the person
who put those statements forward intended
and had a corrupt motive
to prevent the witness from testifying.
But Cohen is at least testifying
that he took those communications
to be a form of witness intimidation,
and was in fact intimidated by them.
So, it is at least laying a groundwork
for further investigations
to probe what in the world
the point of those Tweets were.
- How long did you work
in the White House?
- [Michael] I never
worked in the White House.
- That's the point, isn't it, Mr. Cohen?
- No sir.
- Yes it is.
- [Michael] No, it's not, sir.
- You wanted to work in the White House.
- No, sir.
- You didn't get brought
to the dance.
- Sir--
- And now.
- I was extremely proud
to be personal attorney
to the President of the
United States of America.
I did not want to go to the White House.
- So, this is a good example
of not asking questions
that you don't know the answer to.
Congressman Jim Jordan here
wants to make the point
that all of this is sour grapes,
Michael Cohen wanted a
job at the White House,
he didn't get one, and
as a result he is now
turning against the President.
I don't know if that's true or not,
but what I can tell you is
that he opened up the door
for Michael Cohen to opine
and give his own story
about what happened.
He wanted to make a
speech, but he gave Cohen
the opportunity to directly
contradict all of the points
that he was trying to make.
And on top of that,
Congressman Jordan is acting
in a fairly aggressive way,
which is a tactic that can sometimes work,
but it rarely does,
especially where the witness
is not acting hostile in any way.
- How many times did
the President, Michael,
ask you or direct you to
try to reach settlements
with women in 2015 and 2016?
- I'm sorry ma'am, I don't
have the answer to that.
I'd have to go back and try to recollect,
it's certainly the two that we know about.
- And why do you think the
President did not provide
the accurate information in his 2017
financial disclosure form?
- So, that was a good example
of an open-end question
from Congresswoman Maloney
getting at how many mistresses Mr. Trump
had before he was elected,
and how many times he paid them off.
She didn't get the answer
that she wanted to,
but unfortunately, she didn't
really follow up either.
When a witness testifies that he or she
is not particularly sure about something,
you should always go back
and you should try and get the specifics.
Cohen testifies that there
are at least the two.
The simple follow-up question is,
are there other women
that you are aware of?
Are there other women
that he did not pay off?
Are there other instances that
might have led to blackmail?
Are there other instances
of inappropriate payments
to women or other people that
might have relevant testimony?
So often in this hearing, the
Democratic Congress people
were not listening to the
answers that Cohen was giving.
He clearly wanted to get a story out,
whether you believe that
story is a different question.
But he was giving them
information that they wanted,
and he probably would have given them
much, much more information
if they had just followed up.
- You made some very demeaning
comments about the President
that Ms. Patton doesn't agree with.
In fact, it has to do
with your claim of racism.
She says that as a daughter of a man
born in Birmingham, Alabama,
that there is no way that she
would work for an individual
who was racist.
How do you reconcile
the two of those, Mr.--
- As neither should I as the
son of a Holocaust survivor.
- There's a lot going wrong
with what Congressman Meadows
was trying to do here.
When you have a demonstrative,
which effectively he was making Ms. Patton
out to be a demonstrative exhibit here,
you always have to be
worried about what people
are going to do to that.
Because you're opening yourself
up to further criticism
based on the thing that
you are putting out there.
You can't defeat an accusation of racism
by holding out one single black
woman who you have employed,
as if that defeats that accusation.
It just simply doesn't,
it's bordering on tokenism
in and of itself.
And number two, you don't know
how Cohen is going to react
to this particular gambit.
This is a lawyer's worst nightmare,
Congressman Meadows really
should have thought out
the repercussions of
bringing out Ms. Patton
in this particular venue.
- [Rashida] Just to make
a note, Mr. Chairman,
that just because someone
has a person of color,
a black person working for them
does not mean they aren't racist.
And it is insensitive that
someone would even say racist,
say it is racism itself,
and to use a black woman as
a prop to prove it otherwise.
And I can submit this for the record,
if a colleague is thinking
that that's what I'm saying,
I'm just saying that's what
I believe to have happened.
And as a person of
color in this committee,
that's how I felt at that moment
and I wanted to express that.
But I am not calling the
gentleman, Mr. Meadows,
a racist for doing so,
I'm saying that in itself
it is a racist act.
- Well, I hope not, Mr. Chairman,
'cause I need to be clear
on this particular--
- [Elijah] Well, I--
- Mr. Chairman.
- So this is a great example
of the Streisand Effect
and why you don't make a
big stink about something
that you don't want to emphasize.
Here, Congressman Meadows is
upset about the implication
from Congresswoman Tlaib that
he engaged in racial tokenism
by trotting out Lynne Patton
to refute the allegation
of racism by Donald Trump.
Instead of letting sleeping dogs lie,
he makes a big deal about it,
which allows Congresswoman Tlaib
to read her exact same statement again
and really emphasize the point
that it was a stupid gambit
to make in the first place.
So, if you don't want
to emphasize something,
don't make a huge deal about it,
that is the Streisand Effect in operation.
- To your knowledge, did
the President or his company
ever inflate assets or revenues?
- Yes.
- [Lacy] And was that done
with the President's
knowledge or direction?
- Everything was done with the knowledge
and at the direction of Mr. Trump.
- Now, a lot of this hearing focused on
asset and revenue inflation
by the Trump organization
for the purposes of loans
and other financial dealings.
When you're trying to
get a loan from the bank,
it's the bank's job to
accurately value the property
that's being put forth.
So it's not surprising
that people try and use
very optimistic valuations
of their own property
in order to get a loan.
However, revenue inflation is something
that the bank not be able to double check.
The company is the one that
contains the revenue numbers.
So while asset inflation
is not a good thing,
it rarely gives rise to financial fraud.
Revenue inflation, on the other hand,
is financial fraud and could carry with it
lots of different kinds of liability.
So I wish that the Congress people
had differentiated between the two,
because they focused
mainly on asset inflation
as opposed to revenue inflation.
- [Virginia] So you don't
commit to changing your ways,
basically, because you wanna
continue to use your background
as a liar, a cheater, a
convicted liar, to make money.
That's what you wanna do?
- And that's gonna get me a
book deal and a movie deal
and a spot on television?
I don't think so.
- The Republicans focused
a lot on a potential book
or movie deal from Cohen,
that's an interesting tactic
for going after his bias.
The more information Cohen
gives in this setting,
the less valuable a book or
movie deal would be later on.
On the other hand, the
more famous he can become
and the more central of a player
he is in this whole scenario,
potentially that makes a book
or movie deal more lucrative.
So, it cuts both ways,
but I'm not sure that
that means we should not
believe Cohen here.
So I'm not sure it achieves the purpose
that they're trying to establish here.
- The idea that a witness
would come to us who's flawed,
and you certainly are flawed,
means they can never tell the truth
and there is no validity whatsoever
to a single word they say,
would discredit every
single criminal trial
of organized crime in the
history of the United States.
Because all of them depend
on someone who's turned.
- So this hearing raises
a really interesting issue
that comes up in trial all the time.
Which is, what do you do
when you put a known liar
up on the stand?
Well, if you're the
proponent of the witness,
then you have to explain
the witness's motivation
for why they were lying before
and why they can be trusted now.
And then the most
important thing you can do
is bolster their current
testimony with documents.
Have independent ways of verifying
what they are testifying now is the truth.
Now, if you are the other side
and you're trying to dispute
the evidence of someone
who has lied before,
you obviously harp on the
fact that they did in fact lie
and you should not trust them now.
But you also have to establish reasons
for why they would continue
to lie at the present date.
So for example, if you were dealing
with a confidential informant
in a criminal trial,
you'd wanna harp on the
fact that whatever carrot
the prosecution is
offering to this witness,
is a reason for them to
make up new information.
If the confidential informant
didn't have new information
to give the prosecution,
their testimony would be worthless,
so they have an incentive
to continue to lie.
So of course the Republicans
here are harping on the fact
that Cohen lied before
and cannot be trusted now.
They have a difficult job here,
because the lies that Michael Cohen told
were for the benefit of the President,
especially with respect
to the length and duration
of the Trump Tower Moscow negotiations.
So every time the
Republicans raise the issue
of Cohen's prior bad
deeds, whether it's lying
or whether it is threatening
people with lawsuits,
or whether it is illegally paying funds
to pay off porn star mistresses,
it raises the specter of who benefited
from all of those acts.
And in almost every single instance,
the benefit of those
lies and illegal conduct
is the President of the United States.
The person the Republicans
presumably want to protect.
So I don't know if there is another theme
that the Republicans could have gone with
during this hearing,
but the theme that they went with,
which is that Michael Cohen
is a brute and a liar,
is true and certainly damning,
but it's also damning to the person
they're trying to protect,
the President in this particular case.
- Is there any other
wrongdoing or illegal act
that you are aware of
regarding Donald Trump
that we haven't yet discussed today.
- Yes, and again, those are
part of the investigation
that's currently being looked at
by the Southern District of New York.
- Man, so that testimony is
a bombshell in and of itself.
Cohen has testified that he is
aware of other criminal acts
that surround President Trump.
What I really wish the Congressman
would have done is follow up.
He could ask, how many criminal
acts is Cohen aware of?
Whether there are other people
that had not been indicted yet,
who are responsible for
those criminal acts.
And perhaps Cohen would
respond with the same answer
that says, I can't talk about that
because there's an ongoing investigation
with the Southern District of New York.
But that's a good answer
for the Democrats.
- And isn't it also true
that convicted Russian mobster Sater
even had business cards indicating
that he was a senior
advisor to Donald Trump,
as reported to the Washington Post?
- [Michael] Yes.
- Did convicted Russian mobster Sater
pay rent for his office?
- [Michael] No, he did not.
- So what I want point out
the Congressman is doing here
is he's repeating a theme.
He's asking questions about Felix Sater,
and every time he says
the name Felix Sater,
he says convicted Russian
mobster, Felix Sater.
It might sound ridiculous,
but over time it sticks in your head.
So every time you think
of the name Felix Sater,
you're gonna think of, oh, he's
a convicted Russian mobster.
Of course, the person
who does that the most
is probably President Trump himself,
where he will give
nicknames to individuals
to engender certain ideas and emotions
about individuals by repeating that name
that he has created for them.
So that's what he's trying to do here.
- [Ralph] Let me ask you this, Mr. Cohen,
have you legally or illegally
recorded other clients?
- I have recordings of people, yes.
- [Ralph] Legally or illegally?
- I believe that they're legal.
- [Ralph] Did you tell him?
- In New York State you
don't have to do that.
- [Ralph] So you didn't tell him?
- No, I did not.
- These are interesting questions,
as a practicing lawyer
Michael Cohen recorded
his client's conversations with him.
As Cohen actually correctly points out,
New York is a one-party consent state,
which means the person who is recording
is the one that consents to the recording
and therefore you don't
have to notify other people.
It is unusual for a lawyer
to record his clients,
but it may not in and
of itself be illegal.
If I was a client, I
certainly wouldn't want that
and I don't think I would an attorney
who did record his clients.
But as an ethical violation
or as a legal matter,
I'm not sure that it's illegal.
I'd have to check, but my instinct
is that in and of itself,
it's probably not illegal.
- [Congressman] So in
your testimony on page 13,
you claim, and I quote,
"Mr. Trump directed me to
use my own personal funds
"from a home equity line of credit
"to avoid any money
being tracked back to him
"that could negatively
impact his campaign."
Do you have any proof of this direction?
- This is always a bad
question, do you have any proof?
The question assumes
that there could be one
single piece of evidence
that absolutely proves a particular point,
when in reality when you're
trying to prove something
you use lots of tiny steps
to ultimately get to your end result.
And in response to a question
of you don't have any proof,
the witness could just go off for days
about all of the different
pieces of evidence
that support the things
that he's trying to say,
while not absolutely
in one particular step
proving the ultimate idea.
So number one, Cohen does have proof
in the form of different kinds of evidence
to support his case,
and number two, you don't know
how he's going to answer this question.
He's not going to give up the ghost
and admit, oh, I have no
corroborating evidence whatsoever.
So, it's a bad question to ask,
and it's something that I
find particularly annoying
as an attorney.
Okay, those are my thoughts
about the Cohen hearing.
This is more group therapy
than it is a legal explainer.
Michael Cohen is going
to jail for a long time.
But he could put that time to good use
by learning a new skill,
especially since he's been disbarred
by the state of New York.
For example, he'd really
benefit from Simon Van Booy's
Skillshare class on 6 Steps
to a Successful Writing Habit.
He could channel all the time
he used to spend writing letters
threatening colleges not to
release President Trump's grades
into creative writing.
- And copies of letters I
wrote at Mr. Trump's direction
that threatened his high school,
colleges, and the college board
not to release his grades or SAT scores.
- Or he could take Roxane Gay's class
on Crafting Personal Essays with Impact.
It would really help him
write that Rule 35 motion
to reduce his prison
sentence for good behavior.
- It is for the benefit
of a Rule 35 motion, yes.
- Skillshare is an
online learning community
that has over 20,000
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, design and technology.
The first 500 LegalEagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited access
to must-know topics so you
can improve your skills
and learn new things.
It could even get you out of jail earlier,
like Michael Cohen.
So click on the link, get two free months
and start learning to
think like a lawyer today.
So, do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments.
Check out my other real
law reviews over here,
and until next time, I
will see you in court.